- National Geographic and Mazda
started Assignment Inspiration,
three quests to challenge photographers
to test their ability to tell
a compelling visual story
and to capture inspiring imagery.
- Beth, Nina, Sam,
congratulations to each of you.
Truly a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to compete for a chance to photograph
for National Geographic Travel.
- Just to be able to represent
both National Geographic and Mazda,
I feel like I've been validated.
So I'm bringin' my A game.
- It's a big opportunity that lays ahead.
I think I'm one step closer
to being a Nat Geo photographer.
- It would be wonderful to win,
because what that means is that
someone saw the potential in me.
- This quest is about capturing images
that define what it
means to uplift humanity.
This, for me, really is about
the emotional connection that you make
between the people that you photograph
and the way that you
convey those emotions.
- What's inspiring you
to click that shutter?
The challenge is to capture that emotion
and convey it through your photographs,
so we can be inspired as well.
- You will have only three hours
to photograph your subjects.
It's gonna be tough.
And in the end, you're gonna bring back
your five best images from each place.
- And we're providing each of you
with a Mazda CX 30,
which we hope will
inspire you to inspire us,
to inspire everyone else who
sees your amazing photos.
- When I meet a young photographer
who wants to do what I've
been lucky enough to do,
I can't help but want to be a part of that
and help welcome them
into this amazing life
that I feel I have been lucky to live.
(upbeat music)
- At Mazda, we craft our
cars to inspire our drivers.
Every interaction with the Mazda brand,
we hope to uplift.
It's what inspired Assignment Inspiration.
- When I was thinking about
things that are uplifting,
I thought back to when
I started volunteering
at a local nursing home,
as a high school student.
It left a lasting impression on me,
changing the course of my life.
That's how I decided to go into medicine.
We're at a memory care home to capture
some nice moments with
Kids for Peace students
that are working on activities
with the residents here.
Here we go.
Kids for Peace,
they feel that through acts of kindness,
that can spread peace.
That connection between a younger person,
who doesn't know that much about life yet
but filled with so much curiosity,
and someone who has lived
with this wonderful perspective,
getting those fresh interactions,
that's when it's the most genuine.
I need to be ready.
The name of the game is flexibility,
keeping my eyes open.
Some of it's hard with angles.
I want to be down more on their level,
and I'll go to take a shot,
but then an arm comes in.
That has been a challenge,
but it's fun to push yourself.
(laughing)
- For me, being outdoors in nature,
it's like a reset button.
(upbeat music)
It kind of puts me at peace.
For Uplifted, I'm choosing to focus
on human and animal interaction
as it pertains to conservation.
- Hey Sam, welcome!
- [Sam] Hey, how are y'all?
- Good to meet to you, finally.
- Great to meet you.
- Hi, I'm Denise.
Welcome to Sky Falconry.
- [Sam] Yeah, thank you so much.
I chose Sky Falconry Ranch,
a place where people can come
and interact with birds of prey
in a respectful and natural sort of way.
The emotional aspect of
the uplifted challenge
is incredibly captivating.
- [Denise] If you can capture
how we feel every day,
then I think you're in the right place.
- She could jump off at any second,
and there she goes (laughs).
- [Sam] But I'm worried about
what that's gonna look like,
especially having an entire crew around me
while I'm doing photography.
(upbeat music)
- If I'm connected,
then people are going to see that.
They're gonna feel that connection
and hopefully be inspired by my work.
- A National Geographic
photographer needs to be curious,
curious about the world, compassionate.
When you're intimately invested,
you tell stories that
are richer and deeper.
It comes from the heart.
- We are at Ride On Horse Therapy Center.
What they do here is work
with special needs children
and teach them horseback riding,
motor skills, and how
to connect with animals.
- [Trainer] You wanna pet her?
There ya go.
- I have two children
that have special needs,
so for me to be able
to come out here today
and document this is a
really incredible experience.
And I'm just in heaven.
- [Woman] One, two, three.
- Yeah, so what was
really beautiful is just
that these kids get to come out here
and just get to be kids for a moment.
Time is flyin' by because
I'm havin' a great time,
and there's all this action,
and there's just never a dull moment.
I'm trying to capture them goin' around,
and it's a little bit challenging.
It's interesting she's riding backwards.
Not quite sure where I
should position myself.
Just when I think I have it figured out
which way they're gonna go,
the horses are like, oop, oop, oop.
- The X factor in photography is often
about that moment that reveals how humans
have the power to uplift and be uplifted.
- Children are inherently
inspirational to me.
That energy that children bring
can be really healing.
I mean, it just fills your heart.
Being able to witness connections
that people are making, it's pretty sweet.
- Whoa!
She is in massive hunting mode right now.
- Oh.
- What was that (laughing)?
- She sneezed.
- I didn't know birds could sneeze.
Lots of action with these animals,
so really trying to
capture their movements.
They're really unpredictable.
- If you don't have that
good working relationship,
it's hasta la vista, bud.
- It's such a rare opportunity
to interact with birds of prey,
and it is such a gift
when they actually choose to come to you,
and especially when they
choose to come to our guests.
We at Sky Falconry hold a special permit
that allows non-licensed
falconers the opportunity
of flying one of our birds of prey.
- [Sam] I get that sort of adrenaline rush
that you get when you know that
something's happening and
it's a fleeting moment.
- [Denise] Beautiful.
- As this woman holds a
hawk for the first time,
her face lights up.
This is the moment that I've been
looking for throughout the shoot.
It's not something I
can ask her to recreate.
That look on their face,
the sheer joy they got
is, for me, the definition of uplifting.
(soothing music)
- I'd love if my kids could
do something like this.
How fun.
All these volunteers
out here, it's amazing.
Really neat to watch
all the different things
that they do with the different kids.
They really have it
tailored to their needs.
So I wanna be far enough back so that
the children and horses'
reactions are natural,
but I do wanna make sure
that I'm able to capture
those uplifting moments
and not miss a thing.
Such a great smile.
- Oh my goodness, thank you.
- They were givin' them so much smile
and love when they were walkin' around.
- There were so many different
moments of connection.
I don't know if I was snapping
the photos fast enough
to really convey that in the photos.
But, I felt uplifted
the whole entire time.
- How'd it go?
- I think it went well.
Yes, definitely gives me
all the feels (laughs).
- Really excited about the shots I got
and what I got to witness today.
I put so much of myself into these photos,
but I don't ultimately have control
what someone's gonna take away from it,
and that's part of the vulnerability
of any art form.
- I'm excited to go
home and see what I got.
I know I'm gonna have
my work cut out for me.
Picking five favorites is gonna be
a really hard task.
Just to watch these
children get an experience,
You know, to come out and do this thing
that they might not otherwise get to do,
to just be kids.
I could just see how happy they were
and how much it meant to them.
It was really powerful and heartwarming.